David and Cameron and the first question
is for you guys should we lower the
voting age to 16 would that incentivize
schools to teach civic engagement
earlier and with more urgency I think
schools could just teach civic
engagement earlier and with more urgency
[Applause]
[Music]
class senior year and that's when most
people I believe to take their gun class
I think we should be doing that every
year because that's what we used to call
civics yeah
Cub class is the kids these days call
into that and they teach you like how
government works yeah like things like
Trump doesn't know like there are three
branches House the Senate Supreme Court
that kind of stuff yeah well no it's I
pre registered to vote the other day and
I think that's what we need to be doing
because it right now a lot of the kids
my age are voting the way their mommies
and daddies are voting and that's a
little daunting to think about us I mean
that still happens when people are
adults but you know that there could be
a little bit more freedom as it goes as
it goes on and again that's the number
one predictor of what political party
you'll be part of is your parents past
and that's terrifying to think about
considering that our parents have failed
us oh yeah you really don't like us yeah
okay that's not piss off the kids any
more than me so yeah well the way I feel
about gun reform is we need that we
don't have many limitations on the
Second Amendment right now I owning a
gun my father has a gun Cameron's dad
has a gun I believe both our parents
were in law enforcement I do see the
reason to me the reason to have a weapon
and I do see the reasoning behind the
Second Amendment but I think we should
have limitations on the Second Amendment
the same way we have limitations on the
first where you can't scream fire in a
crowded theater you shouldn't be able to
get an ar-15 if you're mentally unstable
individual I don't get what's so hard
for people to understand about that I'm
not trying to take the gun
remember when slavery was the thing and
women weren't allowed to vote and we did
something about that you know it took a
while well but if the only thing that
comes out of this tragedy is that we
outlaw bump stocks and we raise the age
at which people are allowed to buy an
ar-15 that will be a failure because the
reality from my perspective is you need
to do what we've always tried to do
which is to ban the sale of ar-15s have
universal background checks and also
take away the ability to buy these large
magazines but the problem that is it
makes way too much [ __ ] sense for our
elected officials to take care of yeah
yeah there's a study that's out today
from the RAND Corporation it shows that
these kinds of measures actually have an
impact on gun violence I mean there's
empirical evidence now that shows that a
what's your opinion on like the the fact
that the CDC can't research most of this
stuff and like that's another thing that
has to this guy Dickie nitaac that's his
name this congressman this congressman
put in the funding for the CDC D so they
were unable to study the impact of gun
violence in the causes of gun violence
that's another thing that has to be oh
yes he's like the Republicans Weiner the
other thing is Anthony Weiner what do
you think I meant what's up with ATF
having like all of their records be
paper like that's just insane and that's
required by law right required by law
passed by Republicans who want to hobble
ATF when you've tried to modernize these
things and keep the records in the way
any other corporation or a big entity
would keep them electronically
Republicans have said no you can't do
that limit the amount of times you could
hold on to these things and said you
have to keep them okay we have other
issues to get to Jon Meacham would the
founding fathers agree with Billy Graham
lying in honor at the US Capitol
probably just because it was it would be
a it would not be a violation of church
and state in so much as a recognition of
a cultural figure
Madison who
wrote the Bill of Rights and was a
hugely important thinker about religious
liberty was actually presented with a
case late in his life about why is the
US military paying for chaplains isn't
that a violation Establishment Clause
almost certainly you know in a strict
sense but he said some things are just
not worth fighting and I think that's
where they probably stand Eric if you're
in Jeff Sessions current position would
you resign I mean will you read these
tweets where Trump is going on and it
looks like this is the kind of treat you
would write if you were in the
opposition party why isn't the Attorney
General wait he's got returnee general
it's so through the looking-glass and
Jeff Sessions did I mean you have
nothing in common with them he's a
Confederate soldier do you feel sorry
for him do you feel something no I mean
he took this job knowing who Donald
Trump was right and who he is right and
you know at some point though you would
hope that you would have the intestinal
fortitude or the pride to simply say you
know I wanted this job all my life but
it's not worth it and I'm not going to
take that kind of abuse and I'm simply
gonna tell you you know go screw
yourself and I'm out but he's kind of
doing a service for the country by not
doing that because if right John don't
you agree if he if he left then Trump
could appoint someone who would fire
Lawler here is a sign of where we are in
March of 2018 Jeff Sessions has become a
pillar of democratic order but you're
right a man it should not be confirmed
for the federal bench right right Amy is
there any one particular cause that you
see has the potential to unite the many
different tribes in America's there
anything I think it's pot but a few
things that does unites red and blue
America um you know conservatives yeah
you know I I think of it differently Ted
Nugent
Jeff Sessions would you know I mean look
for the Olympics people come together I
mean a oh yeah I think I'm gonna rally
oh no not to see out there I think that
if if if people will the studies that
are most optimistic in my book are that
if you actually pull people out of their
tribes and have them interact as human
beings enormous progress can be made so
for example the integration of the
military in the 50s was one where
everybody said there's no way this is
gonna work and they went through and
then afterwards there was a prejudice in
America no but what the study showed
that the integrated units were you know
equal or superior to what they said was
when you're forced to actually live with
people talk with them and your lives are
in their hands you you you you see each
other's human being so and same
attitudes towards same-sex marriage to
actually dramatically change when people
started seeing these people as their
neighbors their children you know it
went from like ninety percent
disapproval to sixty-two percent
approval in just thirty years it's hard
to demonize somebody that you know or a
group that you know we have introduced
the Democrats to the Republicans know
it's not just exposure the studies also
show that just diversity exposure is not
enough that can make you hate each other
more you have to actually interact with
each other as human beings
and that's the hard part when you are so
tribal right let me circle it's no
mistake that the civil rights movement
the women's movement the probably the
victory in the Cold War ultimately came
after the mixing experiment of World War
two the sailors on pt-109 were people
that Jack Kennedy would never they might
they would have carried his bag into a
hotel right and he swam through the
Pacific right and he remembered them as
he as he came through and and the
prosperity was important I just you know
we always the tribes come together but
it's always brief and it begins to fall
apart again
I wouldn't over romanticize the past but
I don't think it's assimilation I'm
talking about I mean I think where I get
my optimism is I as I say in this book I
think that alone among the major powers
were what I call a super
that is we this is not saying that we've
met all these ideals but that we have
this overarching national identity
that's strong you know not like Libya or
but it's strong and at the same time we
allow individual sub group identities to
flourish so they don't all have to melt
away I mean we and I think it's if you
look through all the different powers
not not England not France they have one
or the other but it's strong because
it's built around ideas that we're all
different but we are all we all cut into
the same idea and that is what I think
is going away what Eric's doing is so
important too because you can't just
getting people to how do you get people
to buy into this national identity unity
it's not just by cheering the new anthem
very loudly right you have the system
has to seem legitimate and the dream has
to seem accessible to all otherwise
people aren't gonna buy it tell you
about our work cut out for us thank you
very much everybody you were terrific
audience
[Applause]